tonight the roastmaster general Jeff
Ross finally comes up to judge his bench
and into the arena to make his battling
debut roastmaster what's your strategy
tonight he's going against this guy NBA
all-star Mike Griffin
Blake you ready for this tonight it's
gonna get ugly wait I can actually get
uglier than Jeff Ross battle starts now
[Music]
I've been preparing to do my first roast
battle and I've been watching these
battles for years and I got to admit I
bought new respect for the battlers the
prep the psychological challenges in
your head of when to hit when to take
the joke and when to attack it's a lot
to think about I don't have a lot of
comedy experience I just enjoy comedy i
watch comedy most stand-up comedy movies
TV shows I'd watched the Comedy Central
Roast for a long time Blake's a champion
you know he's a championship-level
basketball player and guys like him have
been talking smack
taking jokes since he's a kid so I do
think he's kind of a smack talk expert
all the trash talk you do in the NBA is
just kind of like one-on-one nobody else
is really listening so this is a little
bit better on stage in front of a crowd
miked up for a TV show getting judged by
my pals is gonna be tough but that's
another thing that battlers have to go
through all the time we're big roast
battle family so even though I'm rising
to the challenge of doing my first roast
battle I still feel very much at home
like this is my home court I feel like
I'm the underdog in this situation so I
don't really see it as much pressure
about the pressures on I'm ready
[Applause]
who's ready for the main events our
challenger is no stranger to Slams he
was an NBA Rookie of the Year slam dunk
champion and a five-time NBA all-star
Los Angeles please welcome back for one
night only he's tall and raised a ball
boy
[Applause]
and his opponent from Newark New Jersey
weighing in at way more than he should
he's roasted everyone from criminals to
the President of the United States which
is actually the same thing please
welcome from Brick City the ballbuster o
best of General Geoffrey
[Applause]
[Music]
it's home court advantage why did you
challenge Jeff honestly man wanted when
it comes to this like it whether it's
basketball or something like this I
always want to go against the best so I
asked like ten people and none of them
could do it so here we are
Jeff why did you accept Blake's
challenge because I am the LeBron of
roasting which is still better than
being the Blake Griffin a basketball
[Music]
[Applause]
all right Jeff you know the rules
because you invented them but for
Blake's sake and for pete's sake here
are the rules of roast battle rule one
original material only rule 2 no
physical contact and Blake I am the ref
no bitching no moaning no complaining
and after every battle we hug yeah but
who wants to go first I would love to go
first
[Applause]
just real quick before we get started I
honestly I have some unfortunate Asare
with you guys after working for 24 hours
straight chefs makeup girls just hung
herself in the back yes yes you're ugly
Israel Blake I'm just glad to see you
healthy and ready for the season
everybody talks about your busted knees
no one talks about that busted face you
look like Morgan Freeman bleached
[Applause]
was a good shot there's a good shot
honestly I feel like you could get hurt
but the only way you could get inside of
a gym if you literally the guy named Jim
[Applause]
no listen listen listen guys listen it's
a roast battle you know so Jeff's gonna
take a couple on the chin tonight but um
Jeff I'm honestly like I'm a gracious
guy so I'm gonna let you decide which
one of your chins you take it on 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 chins in my bank account
[Music]
Blake good luck in Detroit that's the
whole joke no no no no no no hold on
good luck in Detroit blink you know what
I think you're just white enough not to
get shot by the cops but be careful
because you're now the worst shooter in
the most violent city in America
lives matter black lives matter that's
good man a mixed-race joke is really
really good considering you look like
the only neo-nazi Jewish person Jeff
you're so ugly today I realized for the
first time that Jeff Ross looks like
Darth Vader after they took his helmet
off
[Applause]
Blake you're half Haitian so it's no
wonder all your teams have been a
disaster with no leadership begging for
help
yeah what do you got you Space Jam alien
[Applause]
Jeff it's it's really funny that you
bring that up you know you uh you're
such a bald piece of it honestly
looks like we both got over by the
Clippers
[Applause]
Blake I do hope someday you come back to
California to pursue your showbusiness
dreams because you never know when how
to ensue me looking for a leading man
that looks like Patrick Ewing a Chucky
doll
you look like pipi extra Longstocking
that's better that's better that's
better like an albino that God cooked
too long
that's good that's good last joke Jeff
you know when people talk about the best
basketball player of all time they refer
to him as the goat and when people talk
about the best roast master of all time
they refer to him as Anthony Jeselnik
[Applause]
alright buddy
you wouldn't get personal I'll get
personal like everyone knows you
recently dated kendall Jenner but what
they don't know is I heard she broke up
with you because she caught you staring
at her dad's tits
[Applause]
and just like the Clippers Kendall
eventually traded you for another
basketball player
[Applause]
do
good the season hasn't even started yet
your ex is already leading you in
rebounds
[Applause]
that's know take a left take a left take
a left take it out take it out that's
I'm not I'm not gonna lie that's really
really really funny but like real quick
let's just talk real quick about the
last girl that Jeff Ross
[Applause]
the last girl that Jeff Ross to see okay
so so if chef if Jeff is 89 years old no
no guys guys let me just let me think
for a second the last girl that Jeff
Ross what guys can I get a second sob
it's not it this isn't a joke like we're
thinking about the last girl that Jeff
[Applause]
I you ever anyone ever blake wait for
the last girl jet rock litter that's all
I got
[Applause]
I don't used to be good I just don't
know that for sure
did I don't know who wins but I want to
rematch either way we go toe to toe and
we come back and we do it again it's a
heavyweight fight
the one-on-one judges
I get to pick who goes first here
Anthony who scored oh this is so tough
Jeff I was describe you as my brother
from another mother but Blake you came
out here as an amateur an amateur
roaster and he gave it the respect it
deserved
I like how you pointed out that I'm the
best roaster of all time a lot of people
don't get that right so I appreciate
that you did and you had some great
jokes my only concern
I hope your hands are okay because you
knocked him out like he was a trainer on
your own team
[Applause]
I vote for Blake sorry Jeff don't take
it personally but it is very personal
Blake Griffin one vote Jeff Ross
no votes Nikki Glaser who do you like I
thought this was gonna be so easy you
know like it's Jeff Ross
it's Jeff Ross the the greatest he's the
greatest at this and Blake Griffin I
cannot believe how hot you are but also
acting we didn't know you could be funny
we've only seen you in your Kia
commercials so we didn't know Blake you
came out with such a dark joke about
Jeff's makeup girl hanging herself which
I just loved and the guy named Jim the
and then the last joke I loved what you
did you'd like you turned the style on
its head you definitely tried some
different stuff you sat on the ground
you let that last joke just sit and sit
and sit and sit and but I I was so
impressed this should be so much easier
than it is but it's just Ricky Nicky
makes it hard I know
Jeff I love that you're dressed like JFK
jr. and his dad's funeral and it's
adorable Jeff the whole time I mean you
brought it the whole time and then when
you got into the the Kendall's the the
Kendall stuff with the dad's tits I mean
it was just another level like Jeff Ross
you won this hard
Wooper Blake Griffin won't beat Jeff
Ross Pete Davidson you're ethnically
ambiguous just like Blake Griffin for
the home team or big homey Jeff Ross
I thought Blake did a fantastic job it's
it's annoying it's annoying how talented
you are I've always said this to my
friends who I hope we could be friends
too
no you're sick I'm a big fan but that
last show lasted longer than like any of
your seasons that that like
really like that as long as but you did
as good as like you could ever do it
like I wouldn't be able to do is that
good also Anthony Jeselnik is the best
roast joke guy of all time him and
Geraldo
so that was true but Jeff you look like
Jack Black in school of crack rock
[Music]
Lawrence is good at piano sorry I'm on
mushrooms Jeff seriously you have me
dying also when you shot it and it went
in I've like never been happier for a
person I wanted that ball to go in so
bad I was like you want Jeff Jeff won oh
my god like Blake Blake bit as good as
you could possibly do in lose
[Applause]
I hope you stay in the roast game bro
it's really fun having a man I
appreciate it thanks for having it was a
pleasure to be the first time you're
going is the master hey I've never seen
a first time roast battler do as well as
play person I am making Blake Griffin
roast battle rookie in the year
thank you
[Applause]